qu'a fait mon petit peu près et ça c'est
le fils de nathalie c'est le mouton une
brebis qui était donné à gilbert pour
les pieds à 75 voix la deuxième
génération de sa mère ne vais pas le le
nourrissage quoi pourquoi aller de son
petit fils mais est toujours un peu plus
maigre que les autres parce qu'on est
obligé de réduire encore les habits l'a
pas fait aujourd'hui tu veux pas attirer
plus qu'à ce niveau c'est un peu des
hommes à l'état primitif yeux durant
votre jeunesse avez vous été entouré par
n'ont jamais si j'ai eu de ces décomptes
j'ai fait beaucoup de cheval d'antan
j'en avais un je vais un peu l'opinion
et puis il qu'un peu été un peu
dangereux parce que tout à fait
inattendue en cela que c'est un peu fou
csii dans les dents les entier selon les
choix entier faut faire attention et le
cheval ch
j'aime ce parce que quand on a dix jeux
suivants
accoucher bientôt et c'est toujours une
âme en belgique ça se passe ce projet
magna journée jamais en pleine nuit pour
quoi et en tous les enfants et assiste
depuis que plus grand 6
ces cérémonies sont très belles ce que
c'est
c'est normal alors on arrive à se dire
que aujourd'hui les choses normales
deviennent très belle femme est
tellement entouré de choses anormales
gilbert bécaud vient de quitter son
appartement parisien pour s'installer
dans une magnifique ferme de 110
hectares près de châtellerault dans le
pot est évidemment la tribu bécaud a
suivi kitty sa femme trois de ses
enfants je veux faire
emilie et anne les débuts à la ferme ne
sont pas toujours idylliques art
beaucoup reste à faire cela ne rebute
pas pour autant gilbert bécaud qui entre
deux tournées mais entre guillemets la
main à la pâte
non ma cravate bordeaux
vous préférez le cheval ou un chien par
exemple ou non j'ai pas de nom j'ai pas
de préférence je me j'aime les animaux
et cie je n'en ai pas eu jusqu'à
maintenant ce parce que je les aime trop
tandis que j'ai cinq enfants vous pouvez
pas voir cinq enfants et quant à niveau
c'est très difficile on peut l'avoir que
dans ce voile a par exemple on peut
avoir que dans des endroits comme nous
ou comme ici où c'est assez grand pour
pouvoir les bêtes soient heureux je suis
content des chiens comme ça dans les
appartements c'est pas possible
gt c'est pas possible pour elle surtout
pour les bêtes et pour les gens non plus
j'ai un amour réaliste pour les bêtes
les bêtes ont besoin de réalités de vie
et je pense qu'à la campagne seulement
les bêtes sont donc dans la nature sont
vraiment heureux je crois
son dernier disque il l'a conçu dans
cette cabane en rondins qui est proche
de sa demeure
elle a la particularité de ressembler à
celle qui a vu naître ses plus grands
succès la cabane du chesnay dans les
yvelines près de paris puis je donnais
rond ce qu'est le chef de la meute
puisque cinq patrons chien car ce qui
est très haut c'est quand je suis pas là
que je suis entendu je suis parti je
suis à paris
il est beaucoup plus efficace que quand
je suis là quand je suis là il s'étend
une veille - faut pas trop passer la
porte quand même a failli veille moi
alors que je suis pas là il fait le tour
des chambres doivent à chaque enfant
ironie fleischer je regarde je n'ai il
est concerné l'un problème c'est je le
pense un peu il
il doit s'imaginer qu'il est seul à
garder et qu'il n'y a que des femelles
de la maison dinac des femelles alors il
doit être regardée de tous il monte dans
ma chambre je regarde si tout va bien
rire des sens et fait tout et elle y est
inquiet ce nouve et puis quand quand je
suis là lors il est lui beaucoup plus
calmes beaucoup plus relax quand
j'arrive je siffle un gros s'appuie sur
dans un coin et de le préférer
c'est pas de préféré mais c'est le chef
vous savez là l'autorité ne se délègue
pas elle se prend il à l'air doux comme
ça c'est un croisement de deux mois ni
noah et de je suis appelé je vais vers
man de dobermann s'est transmis aux
croisements étrange
est-ce que la race pour vous est très
important non non ce n'est pas retenue
chercher un sac à merde vous est
d'ailleurs la race qui pourtant les
meilleures bêtes que le meilleur je me
sens du bâtard du connu
le monde
je soutiens chez bécaud
certains timidité chez vous lorsque vous
parlez des animaux
bah oui parce que vous savez pas et les
animaux c'est un peu comme parler les
gens perdent en espace séquelles
devant les passions de ce qu'on dit
jamais ce qui est jockey l'animal qui
est contredire vos principes je prends
c'est toutes les animations des poux
décochant des vaches des hommes et
femmes
enfant du chien du show qui se voulait
tout ça marche au
bon